this is the technical difficulties were
playing citation needed joining me in
the studio today he reads books you know
it's Chris Joel Oh as what his favorite
going round Gary Brannen goodie and the
bounciest family incident my gray hello
YouTube in front of me I have an article
from Wikipedia and these folks can't see
it all that every fact they write is a
point under ding and the special prize
for particular dancers which is so
undignified today's article is Thomas
True Blood that's a fine Victorian name
I'm thinking oh you're right yes I'll
give you a point for that thank you
born 1856 joseon engineer no not all
quite the opposite in fact a demolitions
expert okay not literally because he
goes
Mel's let in the steam out fly free
water vapor begotten from New York
Thomas Tremont Victorian not an engineer
yeah I'm he's very much in the liberal
arts author no not really more to do
with um spoken words in the written word
was he president of the British shouting
Association oh you're not close enough
for a point but you know you're in the
right area American oratory sad I will
give you the point lesser of oratory and
allocution and somehow said that really
really eloquent maybe or la la and like
yes um Trueblood gave dramatic readings
around the world um he did a performance
of Hamlet what might have been special
about that all he did was rent out some
part products and why it's official I
want it back see I'm sorry allocated I
would like their back when you're
finished winning the first radio
performance of Hamlet a little bit early
for that suddenly with 1908
first slapstick performance upon took
over this omelet to me G to the t30 do
we have to explain the Chuckle brothers
to the rest of me no Julie it's fine
don't Google it yeah do dogs
it was simply one man abridged
production personally schipper III quote
here it is his plan to give the
principal scenes of the play
narrating the unimportant parts like it
he literally just skip the boring bits
Hamlet the highlights oh yeah I could do
that I could double that guy in the
Shakespeare everybody dies
yeah everybody dies Romeo and Juliet
yeah uh the most notable thing in this
article is just titled the jam handy
incident who is ginger handy
well that is literally the question I
would like to ask you because it's a
name I assume it's some precursor to the
Hamburglar I'm for your delicious con
terms you can't stop me True Blood why I
don't know why you run a conserve
business but you see what I'm driving a
city where we're going
did he savagely put dying Jam handy in a
debate ooh yes was this a scandal
because jam handy was of the upper class
and Trueblood was of the middle class oh
and you would want to fight it because
Jam Handy's damn handy
hey it's a it's a wonderful plot but no
it's not
jam handy was a freshman student 17
years old
Henry Jameson handy hence genomic yeah
back I don't think I go with Jam handy
no yeah yeah he got a bronze in 1904
Olympics was out the Olympics where they
had to stop the marathon because the
bloke drove a car and won it um give me
a moment there was one of that Olympics
where the marathon was calling and some
bloke blatantly ran the first hundred
yards got in a car droves me much more
common in the Tour de France in the
early years as well yeah Gary nice miles
1904 Summer Olympics Frederick laws rode
the rest of the way in a car to retrieve
his clothes after dropping out after 9
miles so he dropped out at 9 miles yeah
rode the rest away then the car broke
down at Mile on 90 you I just started
jogging again Oh
to be fair laws went on to win the
Boston Marathon um but the actual winner
was a Brit called Thomas Hicks he was a
Brit running for the US but he had been
doped it would be modern terms um he was
supported by his trainers when he
crossed the finish what they given it
Brandi
yes spot-on with brandy had the point
what
they mixed it oh okay get him in um
marjorine rat poison Oh
strychnine sulfate right when I get
poisoned you in just the right way if
done in just the right amount yeah um he
possibly would have died in the stadium
had he not been treated by several
doctors
why do you say brandy and because it
just seems to be it's just the standard
pick me up again because I do cycling
and following cycle early days the Tour
de France stop have a brandy
crack back on traditional sort of mind
brain and nerve tonic
you know I guess was because we had
Frederick laws Road some of the way in a
car Thomas Hicks technically one but
doped behind by modern terms Felix
kabaah how I might mispronounce I it's a
Cuban postman arrived at the last minute
brownies street clothes
what kind of slowed him down he's bag
full of a post and his hat get an attack
by every dog on the way yeah yes getting
it off all the ladies on the way hung
yeah yeah you just pick up a sarnie on
the way not quite a sarnie
tackle the cow at a bite no not quite so
it's vegetable rather than a potato you
stood in a marrow clumped along with the
unease oh I've been attacked by a squash
how my vents are running these mallory
clogs would on each foot it clogs the
main problem I really I mean I know that
I know check you the Dutch American team
we use them but is the best best to go
out the English language nowhere else in
the world is anyone gonna yell today how
come I win in these Meroe clogs
marie-france I'm famous right now with
these her smash cuts are so glare it in
the Netherlands uh I wrote in this
marrow a clogs no and I'll show that
today it's good um no he stopped off to
have some apples that he took from an
orchard yeah uh why did those actually
slow him down a little bit arsenic
poisoning oh why arsenic nice innit
apple seeds is that arsenic cyanide
cyanide sorry bran wrong thing right
idea well they love crab apples did they
give him a dodgy tummy oh they didn't
give him a dodgy tell me they were just
rock
Oh idiot I wasn't very bright I don't
know if you picked up a rotten out hehe
had to lie down and take a nap and
here's the thing this is why you say 904
this is possibly white stony head
because there were so many things
despite that he finished fourth so
someone's I don't know the other guy got
in the car so surely he actually
finished second because the first tube
cheated well I know the the guy who that
doping wasn't technically offensive oh
I'll say I was here there wasn't
synthetic drugs there right in an
incredibly dangerous cocktail I always
thought to put that in the rules yes
this all the same race this is all the
same this is the 1904 Olympic marathon
but now you said I was he chased by dogs
the postman wasn't one of the other
runners was nearly a mile of course one
of the first two black Africans to
compete in the Olympics Len tau was
chased a mile off course by aggressive
dogs you've got the baby he'll you got a
man cheating in their car you got bloke
on Bradley why the guy who's out there
now and they won't even part of the
Olympics
the Africans running the marathon they
just they were students from South
Africa who in brought over as part of
the exhibit on the Boer War that was
next to the Olympics they just thought
we'll have a go we'll have a gun so the
26 miles line why has not this not been
serialized for televisions guys I think
we found the farm yes
um a long time ago folks we were talking
about jam handy Oh what was about what
was he about again refresh our memory he
he got a bronze in the 1904 Olympic
sized swimming War I she John Gotti's
what he did to Thomas Trueblood did he
heckle him in a particularly hilarious
fashion um not impose started a scandal
about you yeah surely yes have a point
yes once mispronounced something if you
know what I mean and we leave you
another point because it really is if
you know what I mean
I'm bedroom True Blood was teaching I'm
gonna quote here the delivery of short
extracts from masterpieces of
oratory and which was seen from apply in
which a man kneels in front of a woman
pleading for her hand
okay nothing but enduring of color about
that
unfortunately handy then wrote an
article for a newspaper so I guess what
he actually said was going on there
Oh some kind of dirty filth that was not
fit for the stage yeah you can have a
point there he said he said that
students at Ann Arbor were taking
lessons in love making a lesson in
Victorian lovemaking me Manley's knelt
in that fashion lights go off someone
goes out lights come back on she's got a
baby especially oh it works in other
days I think that's accurate how it
works now is that article did the 1900s
equivalent of going viral because old
three copies yeah what every the local
newspaper picked up than the national
newspaper picked it up hmm and all of a
sudden True Blood is sitting there in
you know Superior's office with all
these cuttings around boom guy didn't do
this I quote here from the Chicago
Tribune
True Blood has nearly worn out his
trousers at the knees you got to pay
your way through college son we've all
been there ready fellas um what did
handle I'm hand he went on to do many
things he went on to be athletic
what was his main job parachutist public
relations oh there's a lovely picture
here of the last you know the taught
that the vanity card the last thing you
see when the logo comes up in the oh
yeah okay yeah a jam handy pitch
hahahahahaha at the end of the show oh
it's over
right but Oh congratulations Chris you
win this week hey are you in a miniature
library are to be inserted rectally from
which you can shoot the President of the
United States say yeah Texas book
suppository I was with you I was a
Geisha shoes just about come back thank
you very much to Chris mailmerge to Gary
Brannen to Mike Wright that's been the
technical difficulties I've been Tom
Scott we'll see you next time
the fat people didn't want that the thin
people didn't want that I'm not sure how
well II did business and you know that
was one of the second weirdest thing to
happen outside my office window cuz one
day someone walked past with a wallaby
on a lead Tom Scott had gone in for an
offense whose offensive whose defensive
Tom's got his offensive well knew look
anyway said no um he was killed by a
stinger and this is a coffin right so it
kills with coffins a shocking Bob Suter
folk shark come on over here